[Music]
in Rogue you're an undercover detective
and you were very serious about learning
martial arts for this not just you know
not what's martial arts specifically did
you learn well I wanted to something
because I'm an undercover cop I didn't
want to look - you know - technically
aware and I wanted something that was
much more Street so my wonderful trainer
in London came up with Krav Maga which
is an Israeli close combat system raids
of dirty street fighting and apparently
I have lethal elbows really when you say
it's dirty street fighting I don't know
what you mean exactly just well you'll
use whatever you you have at your
disposal you know rather than you play
dirty you'll do whatever it takes we'll
gosh the eyes you'll go into the
Ghoulies you'll pick up whatever you've
got I mean I could I could really
achieve quite a lot with just a few
things that we have I'm sorry you call
them the Ghoulies is that what you know
exactly what I'm told no I know what
you're I know what you're talking about
I just I swear I have not heard that
have you heard that expression I know
what she means no I know it's almost
automatic isn't it Ghoulies no kind of a
cockney I'll get him in the dailies oh
yeah that's not a Mary Poppins I've
watched that movie 15
no point as Mary Poppins hit someone in
the Ghoulies with an umbrella but if she
did if said she'd be you know yeah very
well protect so those are and that you
use your elbows to get those areas into
the eyeballs okay I have I have lethal
elbows yeah I actually feel much more
confident these days my elbows do you
think you could use it in a real
situation do you think you know not that
you want to but if you think if you
think that you could how many moves to
take a guy down well two eyes and duties
or okay one guru other Ghoulie there's
two Ghoulies okay
[Applause]
you frightened me now